ثماني جامعات استراليه اعلنت تعديل
اختباراتها مصنفه استخدام الطلاب للذكاء
الاصطناعي في خانه الغش المدارس العامه في
نيويورك قررت تقييد الوصول الى تشات جي بي
تي على شبكاتها بحجه ان الاداه لا تساعد
في تطوير التفكير النقدي ومهارات حل
المشكلات افكار وهي منصه حكوميه مسؤوله عن
وضع تقيمات والاختبارات في انجلترا تناقش
حاليا وضع ارشادات اضافيه لمواجهه تحديات
تشارج بالزيت في الولايات المتحده ايضا
وبخطبه الوقائيه سجل اكثر من سته الاف
مدرس من جامعه اخرى في موقع جي بي تي زيرو
الذي يكشف النصوص المكتوبه باستخدام
الذكاء الاصطناعي على اي حال تقول شركه
اوبنائي المطوره انها تعمل على النموذج
الاول لعلامات المائيه الرقميه لتوضيح ان
النص مكتوب بمساعده الذكاء الاصطناعي
[موسيقى]